so months ago i told you that the white
house and donald trump are trying to
normalize coronavirus deaths
so that they're just not notable anymore
yeah people are dying people are dying
from coronavirus every day but we're
sort of moving on and this
it's hard to pinpoint exactly when it
started but certainly it
was a very clear decision that was made
when donald trump wondered aloud about
um injecting bleach and uh
isopropyl alcohol to treat coronavirus
that was where it was like very clear
these are really doing much more damage
these press briefings than they are
helping anybody
uh in the trump administration and so
they stopped the daily press briefings
and they essentially considered that
they had defeated the invisible enemy or
as donald trump often calls it
the invisible scourge trump stopped
talking about it
talked exclusively about the stock
market reopening how we've won and
there's
therapeutics and vaccines on the way we
stopped seeing doctors fauci and burks
on any kind of regular basis and trump
increasingly distanced himself from the
even medical claims that dr fauci would
make and one of the themes of the trump
administration bigger picture has been
hyper normalization and that's exactly
what they're trying to do with
coronavirus hyper normalization
is the making normal of things that
should not be seen as normal including
the
weekly or near daily scandals that we've
seen during this administration the way
in which trump talks to people and
uses xenophobic and racist dog whistles
and has made fun and
of and bullied just about everybody and
i've admitted that even for me because
i'm in this stuff and covering this
stuff every day i have to go out of my
way to remind myself
even though 20 of these things happen
this week none of them is normal if any
one of these things had happened during
barack obama's presidency they would be
one one-week scandals on fox news that
gets us to the new reports coming out of
the white house
and these are reports from people close
to the trump campaign and the trump
administration the new goal is and it's
like of course we knew this
they want to reframe the coronavirus
they want to make the exploding number
of cases and also the
for now lower but still significant
number of deaths
the new normal make people numb to the
numbers if you hear that 400 people died
every day
eventually it sort of becomes i hate to
use this analogy
like kids dying of hunger in africa
right eventually it becomes not about
the individuals it becomes
a number and we're sort of used to the
number there's gun violence and people
die
from from guns from gun violence and
we're not going to stop
selling people guns as the gun people
have said and
people kids are dying of hunger in
africa every day but we're still going
to continue to throw out 30
of our food or whatever it is right as
as the uh uh
phrases phrase often goes and you know
400 people died of coronavirus but we're
essentially numb to it is the goal from
the trump administration and there's a
reason that donald trump talks about it
less and less other than to claim
victory
which is his campaign realizes that
coronavirus is a loser of a topic for
him this is one of the reasons why his
approval rating has imploded his
handling of the virus
the associated economic handling
and recently the reaction to the
protests against
police brutality so the focus will
continue to be
economic recovery jobs ceos
fast food restaurants opening and make
the cases and deaths the new normal we
can live with the virus
schools should reopen that's a focus now
there should be professional sports
we'll have a vaccine any day now
everybody should just keep doing more
and more stuff
even if the case numbers keep increasing
even if we're hitting weekly new case
records
week in and week out and if we end up
with an escalating death toll that
some expect in the next month i'm going
to have a bigger report tomorrow
about the
increase in cases without yet an
increase in deaths
but we may still get that in the next
month hopefully we won't but the trump
administration idea is
if we stop talking about it if we stop
highlighting it
maybe trump's base will at least move on
and maybe the media will start to move
on the the
idea is the public will accept 50 000
cases a day
maybe even a hundred thousand cases a
day if the numbers go in that direction
because eventually there will be a
vaccine and a treatment people will
become numb to the numbers and we've got
to keep the economy open so
my message to you is we can't let them
make that the story
right trump has failed hugely on the
virus
they are doing this they're trying to
normalize the
rapid spread of the virus because they
recognize
that the virus could be what removes
donald trump from office in the november
election
trump's approval rating on dealing with
coronavirus is in the toilet
voters overwhelmingly prefer joe biden
to trump in terms of who
would would biden better deal with
coronavirus than trump has
if we could identify the one moment
where it really went bad
i keep going back to what about if we
hit the body
with isopropyl alcohol and and bleach
and then from there it's been very much
downhill uh
and if the numbers don't turn around the
only choice they have is let's normalize
it let's
make people numb to it let's make
believe that this is just normal
and notice that we talk about that
phrase
an ounce of prevention is cheaper than a
pound of cure
simply dealing with the virus properly
from day one would have been both much
simpler
and much less costly in terms of money
and
lives than now trying to lie to people
to get them to vote for you
we would have saved lives we would have
almost seen a guaranteed trump
re-election if trump had handled it well
if trump had actually dealt with
coronavirus starting on january 20th
remember
south korea got their first case on
january 20th so did we
maybe because of the time difference it
was the 19th and the 20th but within
hours of each other south korea and the
u.s got our first cases
the u.s had low testing and high spread
whereas south korea immediately
developed
tests contact traced isolated people we
could have had high testing
lower spread fewer cases fewer deaths
and
it would be really tough for joe biden
right now if trump had demonstrated
leadership by really dealing with the
virus
i don't know that biden's polling plus
12 nationally if that's the case
prevention is cheaper than cure
avoiding the situation getting so bad to
begin with would have been
way easier than now trying to fix it and
when i say fix it i mean both
electorally and in terms of the virus if
you look at florida texas and arizona
it's essentially out of control you're
looking now at months to reduce those
case numbers just like it took that long
in massachusetts and in new york and in
other places
so just a reminder in 2014
when two americans died of ebola
republicans were demanding obama's head
on a stick
we now have over a hundred and thirty
thousand deaths in the united states
and the trump strategy is normalize it
and pretend that that's just the way
things have to be and i cannot skip this
important piece sorry i hit my mic
because i'm getting so wound up
this goes back to the failures of the
educational system in the u.s
and and the cultural failures as well
especially among the right
when it comes to anti-intellectualism if
you know even a little bit more
about medicine science statistics
critical thinking epistemology media
literacy
a ton of the disinformation that spreads
about the virus would never spread
some of it would but a lot less of it
would spread if you are
slightly more educated you don't fall
for
record job creation in june 4.8 million
jobs if you're slightly more educated
you realize wait a second we lost 47
million jobs
we got 4.8 million back we're really in
bad shape what what the hell is trump
talking about
but unfortunately people do fall for it
so
part of this is education part of it is
you have a willing audience that wants
to repeat
anything that trump says for political
reasons and that's where we end up today
now very very
last thing even if americans grow numb
to the cases and the deaths
i don't know that they will grow numb to
being evicted
i don't know that they will grow numb to
not having money to pay their bills
or to not having a job so that is
something that will be tougher to
normalize for the trump administration
we'll just have to see how it goes
let me tell you real quick about one of
our sponsors cuts
clothing they offer super quality men's
t-shirts and they're giving you 15
percent off
when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's
c-u-t-s because solid color
t-shirts are a really important staple
in pretty much every guy's wardrobe
i think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with
are men's solid color t-shirts so they
actually put a ton of thought into the
comfort the style the durability of the
t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts i've owned
and they look great this right here that
i'm wearing
on youtube is the split hem
crew neck t-shirt very soft
fits me perfectly it's the ideal length
go take a look at what they offer and
once you have it
you are really going to see and feel the
difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing
you will see why and you'll get 15 off
when you do it
by going to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s